con un tercer ensayo de la vacuna contra
el cob y 19 que reporta resultados
prometedores la unión europea se está
preparando para el próximo desafío la
distribución de millones de vacunas en
todo el continente dos de las cuales
podrían recibir la luz verde antes de
fin de año tiff
wish no si todo procede sin problemas la
agencia europea de medicamentos nos dice
que la autorización de comercialización
condicional para by on dec y moderna
podría ocurrir ya en la segunda mitad de
diciembre de 2020 second love of hamburg
change y tuenti la distribución el
almacenamiento y la decisión de quien la
obtiene primero una campaña de
vacunación masiva viene con muchos
desafíos logísticos los preparativos en
alemania ya están en marcha con
prácticas como las que se ven aquí con
los voluntarios de la cruz roja este
centro tiene como objetivo vacunar a
1.500 personas al día en francia se
espera que los médicos de cabecera
juegan un papel clave si es posible
almacenar la vacuna durante varios días
a temperatura de la nevera la solución
más sencilla sería que los pacientes se
vacunarán con su médico de cabeza
y si es necesario contaremos con el
apoyo de enfermeras y otro gran desafío
es ganarse la confianza de la población
a pesar de que el gobierno francés puso
en marcha una campaña de vacunación
masiva contra la gripe porcina en 2009
menos del 85 por ciento de la población
fue inmunizada
desafortunadamente mucha gente no quiso
recibir la vacuna lo que sugirió un
fracaso espero que hayamos aprendido de
las lecciones y que nos centremos en una
buena organización porque es un reto
logístico logistic se espera que la
campaña de vacunación de la unión
europea dure varios meses